soy músico y hoy les voy a hablar acerca
del saxofón clásico y el repertorio
clásico que tiene este instrumento
yo llevo tocando el saxofón
aproximadamente por nueve años a lo
largo de este tiempo he tocado muchos
estilos musicales comencé tocando las
obras que vienen en los libros del
conservatorio están desde jazz
covers después de un tiempo fueron parte
de orquestas tropicales donde tocábamos
salsa merengue música popular música de
bandas de pueblo
la música popular es maravillosa pues se
transmite muchísima energía hace ese
momento yo me consideraba un saxofonista
popular no sabía nada acerca del saxofón
clásico
incursión en el saxofón clásico más o
menos cuando tenía 16 años puesto cuando
fue una clase con un clarinetista
clásico que también toca el saxofón
y fue allí cuando por primera vez
conocía el saxofón clásico con su sonido
sutil y oscuro que me permitía que me
transmitía sensaciones que no había
sentido ni escuchado nunca antes desde
un saxofón
desde el primer momento me enamoré de la
música clásica en este instrumento hasta
el punto que no he cambiado a otro
estilo musical
es por esta pasión que tengo hasta
instrumento ya este estilo musical que
hoy estoy aquí quiero compartir con
todos ustedes acerca de esto
haciendo un poco de historia el saxofón
es un instrumento joven fue creado en
bélgica a mediados del siglo 19 por
adolf sachs
de referencia a su apellido para
denominarse instrumento saxofón
eso fue un es un instrumento
de viento madera pues producimos el
sonido desde que hacemos vibrar una caña
de madera con nuestro aire existen
varios tipos de saxofón saxofón soprano
saxofón tenor del saxofón barítono el
que tengo este momento yo el saxofón
alto
los propósitos de la creación de este
instrumento fueron dos la primera es que
es instrumento tenga un sonido que se
parezca a los instrumentos de cuerda
pero con más fuerza e intensidad como
los instrumentos de metal y el sí y el
segundo propósito es que la digitación
sea un más fácil que el clarinete
permitiendo así tener la misma
digitación en ambos registros del
instrumento
en nuestro país generalmente asociamos
al saxofón con la música popular como
bandas de pueblo bandas tropicales el
jazz y demás cuando en realidad el
saxofón al igual que muchos instrumentos
más tiene un repertorio clásico escrito
estrictamente para este y esto se debe a
que nosotros generalmente asociamos al
sat a la música clásica con compositores
como mozart vivaldi y todos
cuando en realidad el repertorio del
saxofón clásico está dentro de esta
misma categoría y esto no tiene una
pregunta porque el saxofón generalmente
no está presente en las orquestas
sinfónicas y esto se debe a que los
grandes compositores que nosotros
generalmente asociamos con esta música
como beethoven bach entre otros no tan
datan del siglo 19 hacia atrás
y el saxofón al ser un instrumento
reciente pues sencillamente para esos
compositores era imposible escribir para
este instrumento porque todavía no había
sido creado
sin embargo este instrumento tiene un
repertorio clásico que tuvo sus primeras
apariciones de enjambres de sombras y
sería george bizet quien llevó este
instrumento a la notoriedad universal
con un solo en la obra les cierne un
solo consiste en este caso con el
saxofón tocar la melodía principal en un
pequeño fragmento de la obra
después los compositores comenzaron a
ocupar más del saxofón lo que hizo que
el público se familiarizará más con este
instrumento después de los años el
saxofón se lo ocupó al mismo nivel que
los demás instrumentos y ya no solo para
los solos a finales del siglo 19 el
saxofón ya tenía más de 300 solos y
varios cortos
a partir de allí se desarrolló un
repertorio
en donde el saxofón tomaba el rol de
solista y era la orquesta sinfónica lo
que lo acompañaba
podemos citar la rapsodia de claude
debussy los cuadros de una exposición y
el bolero de ravel son de las 4000 obras
donde el saxofón está presente lo que
han puesto definitivamente la presencia
de este instrumento en la música clásica
del siglo 20
porque de aquí se desarrolla un
repertorio inmenso entonces
en donde el repertorio para solista y
para varios formatos más como cuartetos
de saxo 2 con piano y demás
a manera de conclusión y lo que yo
quiero compartir con ustedes es que la
música clásica no es solo la que
nosotros generalmente asociamos con
compositores como mozart o bach sino que
el saxofón a pesar de ser un instrumento
reciente tiene un repertorio clásico que
ese escrito explícitamente para este
personalmente me gusta mucho el saxofón
puede un sonido es un instrumento muy
versátil tiene un sonido muy cálido el
repertorio de ese instrumento es muy
amplio y logra
sentí mi sentimientos y emociones muy
variadas lo que cambia la idea de que la
música clásica
es aburrida y que solo transmite paz y
tranquilidad
para finalizar quiero decir que la
música clásica
y la música en general es lo más
importante pues con este instrumento no
quiere decir que vamos a tocar solo
música escrita explícitamente para esto
sino que la música clásica debemos
romper varios paradigmas y saber que lo
más importante es que tanto ustedes como
público y para nosotros como intérpretes
es que se disfrute y se sienta él lo que
quiere transmitir este tipo de música
para no alargarme tanto voy a tocar dos
piezas la primera pertenece al
repertorio original el saxofón se llama
fantasía en pronto
y es un compositor francés y la segunda
es un vals muy conocido que no pertenece
precisamente al repertorio el saxofón
pero espero que
[Música]
e
[Risas]
y
no
e
[Música]
ahora
no
[Música]
o
no
[Música]
e
o no
[Música]